I can't believe you guys didn't take
advantage especially you and Eddie take
advantage of the area 51 the storming
the [ __ ] Bay yeah we can [ __ ]
amateurs
yeah those [ __ ] is that amateur hour
why cuz only punk-ass amateurs think of
storming area 51 first of all Eddie
doesn't believe in space or any of that
[ __ ] so he ain't going i doesn't believe
it hey we're not gonna talk [ __ ] I love
him he believes whatever he wants what
do you mean he's not I love Eddie wish I
had him on TV doesn't he think there's
he thinks all space is fake yeah well I
mean like calmer in summation comes okay
here's a joke anybody want to hear a
cool joke okay uh uh a Nazi a
Scientologist a Satanist and a pedophile
walk into a bar what do they do
wait say to get a Nazi a Scientologist a
pedophile in a what Satanists walk into
a bar what do they do
I don't know invent NASA that's who
invented NASA Jack Parsons Walt Disney
well ron Hubbard and [ __ ] von Braun
in were the four were the Four Horsemen
of NASA they created NASA so lucky
Callens not here right now yeah I know
he's lucky he's not here right now
because I would crush his dreams like
the last time I was here Brian what
we're talking about aliens and we were
going so hard at Brian yeah so do you
believe in space I do
what is his argument for not believing
in space he believes that dude I'm like
if you look at von Braun right the Nazi
who helped invent a NASA on his we took
over here right yeah so basically after
the Nazis were defeated right yeah he
entered an expansion draft were like the
United States England and Russia got to
draft their favorite Nazis and they're
like with the number one pick of the
draft the United States selects von
Braun right and they took him over and
he helped create NASA but why did you go
like this defeated the nuts because they
weren't defeated they just you know like
they weren't they just they all they all
ran to the Vatican the Vatican put them
in submarines and sent to Argentina
these are just facts there's a ton of
Nazis there's tons of not well or died
in our
Dean I fled Hilliard's rotschild anyways
go on but they had to leave it there was
a roster % his father was a Boris
I can't stood him Stud about uh being a
baker or something like that and he his
mother was a basically house help made
for a Baron Rothschild Baron Rothschild
knocked him up she fled had all this all
his head Hitler a loss Hitler it was a
loss Hitler ellos ellos God has his
doctorate in conspiracies so deep I
don't I wasn't there
it would take me weeks to just go
through everything and figure it out I
feel like if I got high I would start to
get into that world then I do I spot a
book I am bald the Bible talks about
aliens talks about reptilian what Bible
basically Virgin Mary got a train ran on
her by aliens that's the whole story
dude that's how Jesus is an alien Jesus
is part alien he's like the super [ __ ]
he's like almost like Superman I love
you did I really think that whole things
but I mean within the Bible that's what
it says where do you where do we go when
we die well you know there's a couple
things called a it's called the AH
Tibetan Book of the Dead okay and
basically almost like the story through
the matrix basically you die and AH when
you die these beings appear and they
look like your relatives they're like
hey man we love you we've been waiting
for you jerk off the weird ship but
we're gonna let that go how do they know
that
I don't know what add ricotta to because
there we see everything what everything
yeah their watch places I've sucked my
dick they're gonna my grandparents let
me describe Hey
so why would they want to watch that and
so supposedly they tell you to get back
into they go into the light and then the
light you get reborn and you're born
into this supposedly where energy packs
and if you look at the moon there's some
[ __ ] with the moon the moons a little
crazy dude you ever notice that some the
moon [ __ ] the moon is like nothing
else in the universe in our galaxy is
the only thing that has a perfect orbit
we never see the other side of the Moon
right it's why is it there it's too big
it doesn't even make sense why it's
there why is it there it's too big a lot
of people think it's a [ __ ] energy
collector dude now write that when you
die your energy goes up there these
lizard people feed off our energy and
that'll accent you
now here's a whole thing the game
pac-man right you ever played pac-man
when pac-man so close was it look like a
[ __ ] moon so you got these ghosts
going around when pac-man eats and what
happens it goes back into the
regenerator and gets reborn okay this is
this is this is cows here you'd kicked
you in the face this is this is too much
you're really gonna make a man in the
moon no I'm just saying there are [ __ ]
like that that moon the moon is just a
big beautiful thing that that that we
like to look at that's all it is it's
just a planet sure about chicks I'm
working out speakers and not wearing any
socks I have there's only two ways to go
you either talk about conspiracy
theories or chicks working out at
sneakers there is no middle ground
anything you guys touch people up the
conspiracy I find it interesting no it
is interesting but also it's just it's
just as valid as it is it's not valid to
me like like anything else in the world
that's why I can never pay too much
attention or talk if there's space a
space is real in the moon's real you
know but but but it's fun no no no
that's as valid as his point that's why
I'm saying like the guy that says to
[ __ ] the moon is fake is just as
valid to me as the guy that's like no
science has to be dude yeah but I'm just
limited because I just don't have time I
just I'm like okay great both right it's
fine now I'd like to put
Jean our unit but you are though no I
know there's a move I guess okay have
you been up there not happy how do you
know you look up what about what did
they ask the same the moon is in our I
believe that there's a moon in the sky
or a sure but but if somebody goes and
it's sucking you see from souls like
pac-man dude sometimes I feel like I can
see the lizard lizard people late at
night on the moon just just looking down
in our atmosphere
one time I jerked off just looking at
the moon it was so pretty wonderful
thank you the crevices got me hard it's
[ __ ] well that's all faith bro what can
I tell you some real [ __ ] wait let me
tell you something not to get to let's
get off conspiracy there because yeah
but this is my special I talk all about
the stuff that's available at Jesus guys
minutes Sam but so when they do like the
buzz aldrin like the moon landings yeah
they do whole anniversary do you think
they never I see it I just laugh because
I laugh at it cuz I think of you biggest
thing you've what when you do interviews
do they always want to ask you about
they want ask you about your UFC
fighting really why about your special
doing why she about the do you find
yourself talking a lot about that in
interviews do you do that
honestly yeah well yeah this guy went to
the [ __ ] moon and talked about it one
time he did one interview and he's never
done an interview again on it you tell
me you went to the [ __ ] moon and you
did one interview is that true chin how
do we know if that's true do only do
wanted every that before to ever wants
to talk about it what if he doesn't want
to talk about why would do that I would
talk but maybe there's not much to talk
about he's like he's like it's sandy hey
dude you've heard that you can relate to
this I'm gonna give you I'm just just to
be devil's avenues this is what you do
to think about it like this you know the
first guy that climbed Mount Kilimanjaro
you know you know well do you know how
long he spent up at the top how long
five minutes
yeah okay so sometimes the journey is
greater than the accomplishment you know
that in comedy we find the exact right
thing
we got never climate no it's the climb
listen listen he's the first my point is
my point is just like anything else in
comedy and in life sometimes when you
achieve the thing the journey was so
much stronger that it's kind of almost a
letdown when it happens so there's
something that saddens you a little bit
about getting a special about getting an
TV spot about getting breeds dude
sometimes these things
listen hey listen you wanna play devil's
advocate the moon is amazing lizard
people I'm saying it's found me cheese
it is no no it's good to satellites good
aliens I heard it's either Gouda or goat
so do you know that all the [ __ ] wait
hold on let me all the let me finish you
yeah when you achieve things sometimes
they're not as satisfying as you thought
they were going to be when you achieve
something so great like that if you do
believe that don't you think that
there's a part of him that was like I
don't know man it was incredible what do
you wanna say here's the other thing
what do you want to say about it but
here's the other one we don't like him
no say I think he has an ego where'd
that like that's he's the only guy who
does the moon hot living who sells
either lazy balls and he's give him dude
if listenmi listenmi do the same but
sometimes sometimes the journey is so
wonderful you can't express it that way
why is he showing up to these of them
because he gets paid make sure he gets
paid how is he supposed to make money
makes no sanic what answering questions
about the moon at these events though
but he's never given an interview Elaine
are you shocked
they [ __ ] shop you a [ __ ] quote
the greatest accomplishment ever
I know Kai you know what you've talked
about it what Jon's cool about that
something's very cool about that funny
cool cool what do you want to do you
want a mother today's show why not you
want to I not why why would you want to
do someone cause their greatest
accomplishment ever
it's not like he ran a [ __ ] Oh a
one-minute mile or two minute
four-minute mile like I'm talking about
one dude or a couple dudes
first place people ever to go on the
moon this giant thing that's been made
this humongous moment in the Cold War
this guy's done one interview after he
landed what what it makes no sense
okay any other guys done interviews
maybe he's shy he has not had the other
guys okay had the other guys done
interviews
haven't really looked into them well
that's something we definitely need to
look into what if he's the one guy
that's like I really want any putter
what is that you punch that guy in the
face really blossom if he's only done
one interview all agree with saya that's
shady is fun podcast material forever
after moon landing that's it and they
can't agree on anything but after they
land they can't agree on one guy says he
saw stars the other ones like God we
didn't see sucker did we see stars are
like it's like it's time out time out so
we didn't land on the moon is what
you're saying
why if you really want know what I
believe well the Hollywood rights I
think that was faked I think we were
actually on every planet with some
advanced ass technology that was faked
for the Cold War in the [ __ ] just to
beat the Russians and they can't [ __ ]
really show you everything we got
because it's super advanced this is a
problem with conspiracy theories there's
no problem there's no there's no way to
prove it's impossible it's a
never-ending fight you'd have to scour
the internet in libraries for months and
months and months and months even find
out if if that's true because he might
have done a million interviews but you
wouldn't know the only way we know that
how would you know because I've studied
it where I mean I yeah forever but the
internet isn't providing everything well
use though but here's the thing maybe if
you go over the earth is flat right
these are flat it's not like you can you
can disprove that but is it flat years
we've never done it no to me we live in
the simulation I'm not a flat earth guy
I respect the flier with people believe
whatever you want simulation I believe
we live in a simulation yes so we look
at a simulation and the thing we live on
is is not flat i I don't know what we
live ice I'm telling you I believe we
live on a ball being very much live on
the ball why do I think we live in a
ball because I was told that as a kid I
never did any study and everyone's like
what what about this video what about
that video about this video there's all
sorts of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] fisheye lens
all that stuff I think we live on a ball
why because I was told as a kid I have
done no research on my own any of the
studies that they say any of the [ __ ]
formulas that they tell you to tell you
that
Paul I have done none of it and 99% of
people who call me crazy have done no
research either you are just
regurgitating what you were told as a
kid I am fine with it being a ball I
believe we live in the simulation okay I
respect that but no one's calling you
crazy in here no no I'm not in here
people you think people call you crazy
here this is a safe place
yeah your safe place this is so safe
place [ __ ] it I'm just Bruce Lee
fighting 80 dudes Graham and social
media not a safe place yeah no people
yeah yeah let me tell you let me tell
you talk chicks and working shoot you're
working out in sock in dude let me give
you a let me give you one little piece
of not conspiracy anything at all but
it's it's relative to where we're
talking about
absorbing energy in the universe this is
kind of cool Luke Perry was in
Tarantino's movie it was his last role
on time yeah and I just watched it and
it made me sad because I was like man
that satisfy that dude passed away you
know and then I was at home and I was
looking up Luke Perry he just kind of
doing research on him for fun cuz you
know I don't know whatever
and anyway his there was a lie put out
to the world that he was cremated and
and spreaders of his farm in Tennessee
his daughter and this is provable as she
did an interview recently and said that
was not true I don't even know who said
that he was never cremated they put him
in what's called an infinity suit do you
know what this is no this is [ __ ] why
well it's not it's not it's not as
amazing it's all it's kind of beautiful
there's there's this guy that the
scientists develop this infinity suit
that says we're filled with toxins our
bodies are loaded with toxins and that's
a fact right and your toxins whether
you're burnt or put in the ground are
pushed out in the universe in a very bad
way that's how they they say the toxins
bleed out in the and see their mushroom
suit it's called infinity suit so what
happens is you get wrapped and buried in
this and and and mushrooms and other you
can you can pretty much make any kind of
herb or anything
fungal grow on you to take the toxins to
use them for their growth instead of
putting them back out in the universe
and then you will turn into a [ __ ]
hog are a human garden I love the
article talk to all of that about where
to bury you he got buried at his farm in
Tennessee but they just know you're not
a coughing no no no no no no you're in
the earth you're just a thing yeah
they wrap you and make you in the earth
insight right
I always a chopped up and then put in
like some kind of [ __ ] mulch yeah for
a tree yeah but I'll do that infinity
shoot so here's much crazy sue
infinities one fitting suit and then
bury me and Laura came in you want to be
in Laurel Canyon near the record studio
ah just like somewhere along with
[ __ ] odd dude because that's too busy
is too much going on I want to be out in
the middle of nowhere yeah Lorcan
there's a lot of land in this country
lot away bear me on the middle they know
I want to be Montana you're been in
Montana yeah it's got a flat boy hey
[ __ ] you it's not flat at all first of
all and second of all it's not boring
it's [ __ ] beautiful there's no money
there's mountains up there and I'm from
Denver though you know so be cool same
memory yes a mountain range sorry I know
it's flat and it's the same mountain
range now Montana's gorgeous all right
kiss I'll bury yourself in Colorado out
by the airport conspiracy theory let's
not get into the airport let's not go
crazy
grace it blinds you on the walls out
from [ __ ] Denver why why does that
lien on all that land out there why -
now you're queen of a wood gas so I
already know all that [ __ ] yeah she owns
the land she'll go to land by dia yeah a
ton of it and you know that the airport
was built once and then built again you
know yeah I think it's weird that the
Queen just came out and said she's
related to the Prophet Mohammed yeah
what's up with that [ __ ] dude
Anunnaki dawg Anunnaki they created us
and then they created a visa so weird
dude these paintings at DIA ain't the
whole story the fact that all this
attention has been brought to them and
they haven't taken a down says
everything don't care because if people
cuz if you cared enough you would like
look what happened at the improv people
complained about those stupid [ __ ]
paintings and they took em down finally
finally painted over them oh the dolphin
guy yeah yeah yeah Weiland yeah wildin
to Island by the way they got campaign
of the [ __ ] out of a dolphin you go down
to the beaches and he can paint a [ __ ]
dolphin like a [ __ ] whales
whales no it's whales look at Vaseline
fell on the guy that made it killer
that's
it doesn't make sense it does make sense
no no not him not just the guy not just
the guy that made her Emily not just the
guy that made it all for he was the
[ __ ] engine he was the brains behind
it it wasn't just like a worker it was
like the man that had the idea for the
Bronco to be in the air like this whole
thing that someone else died to around
it when they were installing it though I
don't know they died
so people were watching build this
they're like why are you pulling out
that much land yeah why are you pulling
out all this land it doesn't make sense
for the amount of construction to do it
why they ended up Bulbul and go that's
gin dude why is that on the wall at DIA
because this is okay that's my so yeah
I'm a ground tunnel same as that man
they want to scare they want to scare
away tourism did their brain it's - it's
just over piloted what is that I think
that was in one of my bags that fell out
of one of my bags and I was gonna Denver
one time that's in dia - that's the
creepiest that's not in dia oh it is
that is the airport the background yeah
well that's awesome
anyway let me jump backwards yeah off
your [ __ ] phone trip - yeah we're
here for us okay I don't care about the
chicks we're here for us the kid do
you're gonna be guarding infinity suit
right either gonna be buried one you
just changed my life dude thank you yeah
I'm kind of into so much are they I
didn't get a domani domani okay firing
the cake I get 20% off that might be
able to me you guys go to infinity
sitcom use the promo code fighter in the
rocket to get yourself 20% off an
affinity - we do mushrooms and other
spores we're gonna get you more soon but
go to my infinity shoot comm by the way
is infinity so do they sell it now it
says over $5,000 dude that's five g's
dude so then far less over regular
burials say that's how much you like the
[ __ ] of death look at this suit they put
you in like it's a weird thing like let
me see go where Zozo go back up wait go
up look at that up more MORE
hold on call a look oh yeah that's some
weird [ __ ] shell yeah bury me some eyes
wide shut deaf Jim you scroll out like
that the bullet points here here's the
thing though let's say all the three of
us die in here in cat and chin are like
all right we'll just put them in the
yards back here
you can't just be having dead bodies all
over the goddamn plane yeah like
everyone wants to do a comeback
what do you mean you can't have that
well yes you can
no you can't just bury a dead body in
your backyard it's not no dude this you
have to get buried legally somewhere yes
you have to get buried like within
within the laws of where bodies can be
very belong it's your own property you
can bury yourself on your own property I
could until my girl could bury me on my
food you bury yourself here to send me
out so you own it what do you talk of
course you can't I don't think so dude
do you have you die bury yourself here
under this table dude you can you do you
can be buried in your own [ __ ] balls
donation people asking for them for they
know all did they know you just answered
your own question why do we keep turning
to Agent P before because they have the
answers they made the computers they're
searching on they know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about they have the
inside walls in California embalming
your car by law see you gotta have a
permit to bury yourself in your backyard
that's odd dude and this is why I love
libertarians why do I need a permit to
bury myself why don't you pay the
government dollars on the way out well I
don't we can't have you burying yourself
on [ __ ] sunslice right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]